[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to dirty arty the show where we
take Arthur and push him to the absolute
limit of the biggest piece of person he
can be the smelliest the grossest the
meanest look at that face it's innocent
now but it's gonna be different Jake
he's got a beard already - well we are
gonna do we're not gonna shower we're
not gonna bathe not gonna shave we're
not gonna shave we're gonna get a
haircut we're going to eat everything I
think you know we could we could limit
our intake to just candies and stuff but
the way I see it it's all good
let's just just down everything so
anytime we rob a place or we get you
know we hunt something and we have a
bunch of meat we're just gonna eat it
all I think that's the best way so we at
any point we can never have or just to
clarify we can ever have any food on us
I'm purging as inventory right now we're
gonna be mean we're gonna tag in eyes
everyone we're gonna rob stores we're
gonna be the outlaw we're gonna see if
we get that that honor system - its -
it's a left-hand side of the screen
we're gonna be an [ __ ] we should
probably be drunk - and we can we're
gonna need a fit for dirty arty and you
mentioned Jake that in the town of st.
Dennis on this and uh you're correcting
me sound na there are some really sweet
gross looking outfits so should we just
head right to Sandy like a madman yeah I
got a cigar - just like I haven't like
footlong cigar - yeah I mean I think the
other thing we were talking about which
is interesting with this letsplay kind
of series we're doing is I have been a
pretty good boy
when I meet - it's it's kind of hard not
to be or
hard not to do anything different like I
I it's tough I wish you see there I want
to suit some oxacactus Oh we robbing
this you better believe it oh oh well
we've got some canned vegetables you
know what that means eat them and you
also got a crime reported yeah whatever
well they stopped the train that a whole
left side of his body's got hurt yeah
you're most gonna you almost gonna die
tonics yeah just took a remedy
all right I guess I didn't quite fit
under there all right off to a poor
start all right we got some meat all
right and Appell cook it that is so much
food think about it
yeah he's already eaten quite a bit I
got another one too he can cook so you
also said that you can get beard oil you
told me this to make your beard longer
we can get some of that and some Denis
you
oh my god I have to yeah yeah we want to
go to the trapper right let's go to the
trapper and see what we can get I need a
perfect badger oh damn you're only a few
dollars short
but I also need I need a perfect beaver
pelt oh my god I think the skunk is the
one who snuck is the one we need
I wonder where you would find skunks so
all the clothes at this place are pretty
expensive though and they're like pretty
fancy and then forget it let's go to bar
that was quick have to do anything oh
dang oh two-on-one nice I want a drink
oh god I love how quickly you got a
fight you just worn one thing in this
fight talk to your mama like that mister
don't talk
idiot with you look why don't disturb
them nerving to be verbally could you
punch the freaking pose that's amazing
unarmed assault no it's happening again
Wow yeah get all those witnesses oh this
is perfect
hmm they're mad at me because I'm wanted
[Laughter]
cuz I smell bad man I wonder how high
your bounty can get I have a feeling
we're gonna find out through the course
of this like there's a bank inside oh
can I not go in yes all the doors open
though it's a lot of police officers
yeah I'd say so yes
yes one stick of dynamite oh do it do it
now oh my god like that thing oh my god
Oh should we go back to like Valentine
or something and check out those stores
maybe or like strawberry or we could go
to Rhodes Rhodes is on the way oh you
know what okay in its own Valentine
there's a gut there's like a trapper guy
in the bar it was about the guy with the
raccoon a raccoon yeah we could get that
this is kick his ass and take this hat
because once you get once you take to
his hat you automatically always have it
we can fast travel there we get two rows
we can see if they have any funny
outfits okay that sounds good although
we don't have a lot of money I don't
know if we're able to afford anything
well at the very least we can rob some
stones
it smells about to say we can try to we
could we could at least get an idea of
what a what a fit I mean even if it's
just a jacket I feel like we can afford
jacket yeah
I looked away for a second oh oh oh oh
we're good so yeah that's the other
thing is like because we're acting like
such a freaking [ __ ] the music has
kind of shifted to reflect that right
from Kevin can you imagine like are you
serious oh my god oh my god
if you're really cool if it's a witness
for assault just witness everything I
think it's too early the shops aren't
open yes you know what that means if you
go up to the door you can fetch or
change time yeah but we could also just
get pissed drunk and getting a fight at
the bar like I wants to fight you so bad
or about you Oh guys look I think I know
that guy in real life just like won't
stop talking my god the town's really
falling apart huh like no one in town
likes him so I take my shot
I'll see how your fighting skills are
when you're drunk oh that's immediately
live dang that was an awesome fight
after that fight you deserve it
alright it's morning now [ __ ] - every
person smoking drunk scold that dog no I
can't do it let's get a new jacket and
then go to Valentine and get a hat man
that plaid jacket all like muddy dog
yeah we look good the white one the
white one would look would look worse
yeah that's a good point
alright oh I can't buy it I can't afford
it I'm ten cents short
I can sell something yeah I'll sell the
hair pomade because I'm never gonna use
that as dirty earth they're looking at
you probably done nice all right now
let's go punch them in the face and then
go to Valentine
if your [ __ ] of a mother could see you
now oh that's a nice little chunk of
change we should also get some of the
beard oil I'm surprised that got us $30
that's goes the show yeah living a life
of crime is worth it
[Music]
okay be decent good point
how are you shut up see it's already
happening you're becoming a oh I thought
you're stealing it for something he just
keeps on reappearing I've bought all the
chocolate all right put all I put all
that stuff in your belly and put that
crap in your hair didn't someone just do
that just throwing it on the floor oh
[Music]
dang oh oh what oh you're gang members
did it oh Sh
oh my god that was nuts dude
they're just tearing apart this town we
killed them all all right so we got a
coat we got a bunch of food in our
gullet a lot of chocolate a lot of rum
you got some hair tonic to make our hair
grow we got a lot of stoves in our
system we're looking good
so let's let's stop here all right and
then I say next week we try to find that
hat yeah we'll get that hat my mommy
other things okay thanks for watching
and uh you guys all take care see ya
[Music]